and welcome to hannity and we start this
friday news night with a fox news alert
now tonight we are nearly a month into
putin's hostile invasion of a sovereign
country ukraine and russian forces are
very much stalled all over the country
now no matter what happens moving
forward this war has been a humiliating
disaster for vladimir putin and now the
little murdering thug that he is is
lashing out this morning russia launched
a missile attack in western ukraine and
in the south we continue to see
relentless shelling of civilian areas
now the same type of
medieval siege
would also be happening in key but thus
far russian forces have totally failed
to encircle ukraine's capital city good
news for ukraine now russia's military
performance has been incredibly pathetic
but in coming days and weeks you can
expect the carnage the bloodshed to
increase as putin desperately looks for
a way to save face and meanwhile back at
home in moscow putin is facing more
humiliation russia's currency is now
crashed moscow stock market has been
shut down for weeks anti-war protests
have erupted all over the country and
today during a big manufactured
pro-putin rally in moscow his best
attempt to look like donald trump there
were some embarrassing technical
difficulties during vladimir's big
speech
me
[Applause]
oops vladimir putin can't get through
speech without screwing that up kind of
like joe biden anyway according to
reports the stadium was filled with
thousands of government workers who were
required to attend unlike a trump rally
anyone in russia who voices opposition
to vladimir putin's war in ukraine
they're thrown in jail vladimir putin is
not in a good place and right now the
world is facing an extremely dangerous
and critical
tipping point and what happens in russia
and ukraine will have reverberations all
over the world but guess what our
fearless leader joe biden he's taking
another weekend in delaware a lot of ice
cream a lot of nap time and before
heading out joe did have a call with
china's president president xi to
discuss ukraine and other issues of
mutual concern
i hope someone reminded joe that china
is not to be trusted they have their own
territorial ambitions in the lead-up to
putin's invasion the biden
administration they shared u.s intel
with china and asked them to discourage
russia from attacking china did the
exact opposite and they immediately gave
our intelligence to vladimir putin and
russia now as we speak china is very
much aligned with russia in every way
the country is now a major purchaser of
russian oil and gas and of course
russia's oil and gas revenue
is what makes putin rich and russia
richer again and the higher the price
the more money putin has to spend on his
bloody war and his territorial ambitions
now the u.s could drive down the price
of oil and gas right now by drilling by
fracking by re
by refining by producing more fossil
fuels here at home getting in more
canadian
oil from little justin he's willing to
do it but the climate cult eco-socialist
that is the new democratic socialist
party they're standing in the way and
despite record high gas prices we're all
feeling the brunt of it congressional
democrats are calling on biden to
declare a national climate emergency and
shut down all drilling on all federal
lands are these people that clueless
they're also calling up biden to end all
energy subsidies for the oil and gas
industry and meanwhile more than 65
celebrities oh this is great and now
protesting a canadian pipeline with a
strongly worded letter they're very
worried about the environment except of
course when they themselves need to
travel many of those celebrities on the
list yeah they're frequent flyers on
their private jets led by leonardo
dicaprio jane fonda ben stiller uh
robert downey jr what hypocrites right
one pipeline protester a model named
lily cole said that she prefers to take
helicopters everywhere okay i'm not
against helicopters i love them it's a
great invention but you can't lecture
the american people and you can't shut
down pipelines if you want to fly around
in your private jets and helicopters
nothing wrong with any of that but spare
us the lectures about climate stop
telling american citizens to
start driving electric vehicles and
their need to conserve energy and go buy
yourself an electric car well that might
cost you 60 grand then you got to pay
for the power station and for the love
of peace by the way stop faking support
for ukraine after all anyone who really
wants to stop putin you would do
whatever it takes to drive the price of
oil and gas down and supply our allies
in europe with their energy needs
whether you want to face this truth or
not it is a reality the lifeblood of the
world's economy is based on oil gas and
coal period it's not going to be
windmills solar panels won't cut it and
until we get clean new sources of energy
go out and find it
that is what the reality of the world is
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else